all right well i understand that you
have a new addition to your family right
winston unbelievable the cutest
are you kidding me look at that look at
his eyes are they like a green or a blue
what
they're hazel they're like mine me too
i'm hazel so get close
yeah get close
um i love winston so did you name him
after anyone special
i will tell you this like you know uh my
you know my mom
my son's mommy and i we're not together
we're we are divorced
but the best of friends so
yeah so she's been actually staying with
me this whole time during this uh
yeah because you know they said you know
social distancing and it scared me and i
was like
well if she's not going to be with us
then then she's not going to be able to
come visit joe
or or if he stays with her then i'm not
going to be able to visit him
first that's great yeah so i was just
like stay with us let's just stay
at my house all together and uh she
hasn't left
she's she's like hanging out she's like
nah this is nice
she's grabbing here's a mask no she's
great and
that's that's another thing that i will
say about this pandemic it has
brought us together and and you know
it's this
it yeah we're not together but the
family was strong like we
you know we were there for for joe
together to show that yeah that for your
kid you're capable of doing that
yeah it was a beautiful thing and that's
why we got the dog that's why we got the
dog
the dog just brought joy to us it was
just like we were there was times where
we were so dark in the house just
animals yeah subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel
subscribe to my channel please don't
make me keep going